c'est un roman choral donc on a
plusieurs personnages on suit vraiment
les quatre destins des personnages et il
se retrouve un petit peu tous les uns
les autres
speed booking réunion de passionnés de
lecture autour d'une table pour faire
découvrir leurs coups de coeur mensuel
le tout en 5 minutes
alice line douzaine de livres par mois
c'est la sixième fois qu'elle participe
à cette opération à la médiathèque de
montigny celle échange les changes la
découverte de nouvelles choses des
choses qu'on lit pas forcément faire moi
je vais lire plutôt de la littérature
l'imaginaire par exemple mais on peut se
retrouver avec quelqu'un qui au
contraire d'ailleurs que du contemporain
ou que des policiers et du coup c'est
une ouverture sur de nouveaux styles sur
de nouveaux auteurs
le speed booking a été créée à
l'initiative des bibliothécaires
une façon d'être en contact avec le
lecteur et de partager ça nous d'être le
voilà le fil rouge le médiateur donc oui
une boîte de possibilité de faire de
faire découvrir la bibliothèque et les
bibliothécaires aussi pour échanger et
découvrir de nouvelles lectures le spi
debout qui s'est tous les premiers
samedis du mois